jetzt scheint der treppe hoch und dann
kontaktieren
ich treffe ich treffe nicht nein
und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge handicap games und das
heutige handicap kommt vor
wir machen das bestellte vergleich an
das heutige handicap kommt von max
selbst und zwar machen wir ganz simple
sache aber ziemlich übel wir tauschen
heute einfach links und rechts straif
live.de und stride wird jetzt achte
scheiß
das ist wirklich nicht was ich gern hat
mit dem oft so so hat die neuen grenzen
aber das hat dieses treffen also in den
kampf ist dies aber so schwierig so
schneidet man hier mit der maus und dann
im kampf komplett ohne witz ist als ich
habe schon probleme mich zu bewegen ich
sterbe chef schon in der bewegung ist
hier runter weil ich einfach nichts
raffe es ist ja ganz vorteil dass man so
eigentlich
über die maus links um die ecke
ich weiß ich bin ein anderer richtung
nein lass dich leben im loch treffen
ach du scheiße leute ist das heftig ist
das heftig ich stelle jetzt aber soll
das ich nicht links und rechts laufen
muss man viele gäste gern links hoch
laufen so richtig auf dann wird einfach
heftig weiter aber ich kann es mir
halbwegs einprägen so also halbwegs heil
fixed rate zack das dahin
ok man kann halt auch viel über die maus
machen das ist wahrscheinlich der
vorteil aber wenn du wirklich mal der
kampf situation ist und du dich einfach
deine instinkte verlassen muss dann ist
feierabend
keine ahnung
seitwärts bewegen oder sehr gut okay
aber zumindest mal angeschafft
einfach links rechts das ist dass es so
ein break
ihr wollt einfach in die andere richtung
laufen vorn und hinten machen
also leute jetzt hardcore-modus vorn und
hinten werden auch noch vertauscht oh
mein gott
adwords führt w3work was da durch
wie seht ihr das kein fake ist will er
da oben ist euch die taste für filme
eingestellt er aber ach du scheiße wenn
du dann diesen momenten wo eigentlich
aus reflex handels rückwärts links rum
wenn der gegner vorrecht von rechts
formiert moment moment du dich raffen
alles klar
ich habe jedes mal nach hinten gespielt
wurde
ich hab nix o mein gott du hast
hineinlaufen ich rückwärts
ich hab's geschafft
oh mein gott kraft steht irgendwo erhält
das war so offensichtlich dass die ecke
warten würde ja und acht stimmt der
trend wenn es so ist es etwa so ihrer
damit dem bvb rumzulaufen ist das auch
so ich denke auf einen appell die tasten
sind an den rand liegen also ich denke
so ok drückt jetzt auf oder sowas ja
aber so zeigt gerade gerade die lauf
tasten der so automatisiert ist einfach
so ganz tief abgespeicherten dass wir
das alles nicht alles genau den wir
gebraucht danke ich glaube bei dem aber
wie so ein millimeter
das ist hier nämlich an
die web in der ak entstanden ist ja noch
ganz schön gut dabei was habe ich das
gesagt nein ich war wirklich dumme
sachen sowie maxime ist der coolste
trinken
pfeil abgeschossen jetzt ein thema das
ist so unfair aber auch weil ich ja auch
weiter
lauft links sind dann aktiviert habe ich
eh nicht
er eröffnete hoch
ich treffe ich treffe nicht nein ich
habe nicht getroffen weil ich einfach
dumm dumm gelaufen aber so ist die
unmöglich die technik ist viel zu heftig
so fallen gegen team aber ich würde
sagen acht minuten hinterher
sg ankaufs einfach einen karton kennen
okay okay dann links ins gebäude okay
hier einfach mal sterben heute ich gehe
dann einfach mal sterben macht's gut
sie wissen was alles ist die bosse wenn
er zur waffe hat es ist einfach es ist
so schwer machen ich habe dich es ist zu
schwer hatte ist ja aber irgendein
gegner
das ist nicht okay ist wenn wir weiter
nach vorne und hinten vertauschen und
links und rechts hat detlef gelegt
vorgelegt die hacken weiß man nicht aber
okay das gute ist wohl nicht sagen ich
weiß einfach selbst nicht wo ich in all
so wenn ich selbst nicht weiß dann kann
es den gegner zu verwirren aber naja gut
wird sagen heute wendet scheint gefallen
hat dann könnt ihr gerne einen like dass
ihr kommentare schreiben
wenn ihr eine idee habt für das nächste
handicap für die nächste handicap games
folge und ansonsten würde ich sagen
als 20 verzweifelter ins bett med